All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week. First one is
David, based on the numbers we're seeing
about loyalty to Donald Trump and people
willing to leave the Republican
Party if he starts a new party.
Is it fair to say that Donald Trump's voters are
more loyal to him than Obama and Biden's voters
are loyal to them? I think that there's
a complexity to this question, because
what we mean by loyalty may not be the same
thing. If what we mean by loyalty, we mean
lack of willingness to criticize them.
In other words, you're loyal in that
you'll never criticize anything they do. I
think that, yes, Donald Trump's followers
are more loyal to him. You see, many on the left
who vote for voted for Biden, voted for Obama,
voted for Obama for reelection, and yet had many
criticisms of them. And some might say that that
means they're less loyal. I don't know. I'm not
so sure about that. I think that one of the things
that does that is unique to the Trump voter is
that because many of them either were sort of
like disaffected Republicans who already had some
disdain for the Republican Party or were brought
into politics by Trump. And if Trump had been
a Democrat, they would have become Democrats.
Trump ran as a Republican. So there, you
know, putatively ostensibly Republicans,
they don't really care about the Republican Party.
And when you think about all of these folks who
joined politics essentially to follow Donald
Trump, they liked the dog whistling on the
xenophobic sort of racist stuff. They don't really
care about abortion. Like, you know, Trump made up
this thing about how he used to be pro-choice. Now
he's pro-life because he made a kitty like there's
something like that at 68 and then he became
pro-life. And so that appealed to some of the
evangelicals. Most historical Republicans went
with Trump because they weren't going to go for
Hillary. But the people that Trump brought in,
they don't really care about most of the stuff
that a lot of Republicans care about. They'll go
with it if Trump wants it. But they're not really
about the debt. They're not really about abortion.
They're not really about religious liberty.
They liked the sort of vibe of Trump and the
dog whistling that came with it. Trump came in
and he said, you know, George W. Bush was wrong
on the war and Mitt Romney sucks. And, you know,
John McCain. I prefer war heroes who don't get
captured and Obama might not even be American and
Mexican rapists and all this different
stuff. And that was really what they were
motivated by. And so it's less to me that they
are super loyal to Trump. It's that they don't
really care about anything else that's going on in
the political world. They never really cared about
anything other than Trump's words. Even Trump's
actions they don't really care about. Remember,
about seven or eight months into Trump's
presidency, I got a call from some guy in
California, I think it was, who said, you know,
Trump's just the best. Everything he's done.
I said, well, what has he actually done so
far? And he didn't actually list anything.
And I said, well, what motivated you to vote for
Trump? What promises did you like? And he said,
building the wall. I said, OK, so if there's
no wall across the entire border in November
of twenty twenty, you're not voting for Trump. And
he said, no, I'm probably still voting for Trump.
They don't really care about issues. They
care about Trump because of the things he
says and how he says them. And in that way, it's a
debate, whether you call it loyalty or simply they
don't care enough about anything else to consider
abandoning Donald Trump. I think it's the latter.
You tell me whether the term
loyalty does or doesn't apply